U.S vice president Kamala Harris has
visited the demilitarized zone
separating South and North Korea amid
heightened tensions Harris earlier held
talks with South Korea's president Jun
tsukyol where they both condemned North
Korea's nuclear rhetoric Pyongyang fired
two short-range ballistic missile tests
just a day before Harris landed in the
region Yoona and Harris discussed
strengthening their nation's Alliance as
well as improving ties between Japan and
Seoul covering this for us is Rob
McBride who's standing by for us in paju
in South Korea Rob what does this visit
mean for the security alliance between
Washington and Seoul
foreign
visit coming at a time of increased
tensions in Northeast Asia in particular
Kamala Harris at the moment is right on
the DMZ we are a few kilometers back
from the DMZ but just to further up the
border from here she is at a lookout
post that looks down into North Korea
itself very close to those famous blue
Huts of panman John the truce Village
but earlier she also met with uh Yun Suk
Yol of South Korea talking about the
importance of this alliance between
South Korea and the United States
lasting 70 years and of course it comes
right on the back of the visit for the
state funeral of Shinto are they in
Tokyo again the visit by a U.S vice
president showing I think the importance
are that the U.S places on the alliance
with Japan and also with South Korea at
a time of increasing tensions and also
with the increasing growth growth of uh
from China of its expansionism of its
aspirations in this part of the world
we've heard from Joe Biden the president
reaffirming his commitment to Taiwan so
this is all very much tied to assuring
up support in this part of the world and
the administration here in South Korea a
conservative Administration is
re-committing itself to working uh close
more closely with the United States when
it comes to military cooperation so
we're seeing at the moment for example a
very large jointed Naval drills
happening off the east coast of the
Korean Peninsula involving the Ronald
Ronald Reagan at one of uh the United
States Nimitz class aircraft carriers
it's the first large exercises taking
place like that since 2017. and Rob has
there been any reaction from North Korea
to Harris's visit
you know just as we as we see a military
cooperation picking up we're also seeing
a return to an awful lot of the rhetoric
and the uh the the combative language
from North Korea and also a lot of its
testing and in fact
um we are expecting according to South
Korean intelligence officials that the
north has completed preparations for
another nuclear test now they haven't
done a nuclear test since 2017 as well
so you do get this sense of things
slipping back in time just Wednesday
evening we have the launch of two more
short-range ballistic missiles there was
another on Sunday there has been a
continuous missile testing really since
the start of this year and it was only a
few weeks ago that the North Korean
leader Kim Jong-un
announced that North Korea had arrived
as a nuclear-armed power it's now
enshrined in law and it's worth bearing
in mind that the last major U.S
leadership visit to the DMZ was 2019
that was a president Donald Trump when
he famously walked between the blue Huts
shook hands with Kim Jong-un stepped
across into North Korea at the height of
all of that Summit diplomacy with hopes
that we were about to see some
breakthrough and having the north agree
to denuclearize I think this visit back
to the usual sort of going up to the DMZ
meeting
the U.S personnel there and staring
across into North Korea that you'd never
actually we are not meeting with at the
moment I think that kind of shows you
where the relations have slipped to at
the moment indeed all right we
appreciate you breaking all down for us
Rob McBride laborers in South Korea